you're doing me so much clothing
sometimes I like to dress up queer I
star Anthony Borowski cleans up nicely
at City Harvest his 35th annual gala in
NYC on Tuesday a very different look
from this stripped down version of the
actor modeling for fame underwear when
the Hanes partnership started which I
couldn't be happier about it was a good
opportunity to sort of like cut out
dairy for a little bit and work out
twice as much and do a lot of hot yoga
and SoulCycle and yeah now I'm back to
eating cheese I hate you I hate you by
the way I was trying to think of a some
kind of joke to make about that if you
can look that good and your underwear
you should do an underwear campaign but
I should also point out that you
following the long and Noble tradition
of Burt Reynolds Joe Namath you probably
don't even know who that is he's
Canadian you know actually I think Burt
Reynolds might have been completely nude
it just sort of you know strategically
covered but I mean there there are a lot
of hunky people who have done that over
the years so I'm proud of you more power
to you
[Music]
you